welcome to this video yep new game here
against gren okay i played this guy
before in 15 min and lost I have no
memory about that not sure if I'm this
is even on video I sometimes play game
some just um just without any recording
so don't know if this is some documented
on the channel it's kind of funny I had
a game before that in the 15 million
pool also was against in a region player
with the very similar raiding this time
we got be five so let's see okay he's
taking only fall that's an interesting
variation that I don't know very well
now flex idea is to quickly um attack in
the sand down the d5 I know that King
edge one is the right move I know he
goes a 6mm king edge one because this b6
g one diagonal is some time sensitive
he's six yeah like can play with b5
sometimes
yeah the normal-looking most obvious
move or something like Bishop g5 just
developing this piece pinning the night
I wonder them okay looks normal also
moves like night be three come to cons
come into consideration just trying to
attack this Bishop f4 is also that I
kind of like I wonder if a sex is also
in some way preparing the multi5
instead of a 6g five I think there is CD
CD Bishop g5 so if i play move like
Bishop f4 the move d5 might actually
beam be feasible channel I don't know
what is right Bishop g5 Queen a5 is
irritating IDM tween 8522 night 64 this
kind of thing can be very irritating 94
Fe for Bishop deform yeah it looks a bit
strange Bishop g5 Queen FM ok I have
bishop age for maybe ok I'm putting
putting this out it shouldn't be
terribly bad i spent ages here right wow
ok he played quickly probably still
knowing what to do yeah age success of
course quite often useful Oh g5 that's a
very straightforward way to do it came
yeah it weakens f5 very very
considerably okay I didn't want to play
Bishop d3 and run into night h5 so this
is why I went to have to a g5 is for
high played this very quickly I mean
maybe he he is following him some kind
of known variation but generally
speaking g5 looks quite bad to be honest
at the ricans really a lot okay so d5 if
I take on d5 let's say and play queen
bee three isn't this good just
pressurizing this yeah okay let's start
with the move on top of everything i'm
also much better developed him so queen
bee three was my idea is there a
drawback
that looks fairly logical it also i mean
just a text d5 if you take c for Bishop
c4 I'm attacking f7 and this already
looks like like it's running out of
moves a little bit so what what is his
move actually yeah yeah I thought cd5
and I'm a pawn up isn't that the case
hmm but mystified here it looks like I'm
a pawn up or not cd5 and yeah let's do
that I way maybe can he play 95 and I
can like somewhat tactic but opening up
the position with all that holds looks
kind of strange amazing really this is
working I don't believe it okay Bishop
g7 mileage I mean Bishop g7 is a very
obvious continuation that's just the
question is something better okay come
on this is just pretending to look for
something else oh wow and this I didn't
even consider
thought rook t1 is just is just toast
how is he not losing after root you on I
don't see it and this is a piece Bishop
takes root cheeks tempo on the Queen and
I cannot even take my bishop on you two
I d5 look term looked very mistimed
especially in connection with g5
now come on don't tell me you're letting
the clock run down now I really have
something better to do
okay so i think that around here he
should should do something else I mean
Lang resign and now it is resign if we
go back him here sorry before Jafar this
is definitely a normal theoretical
position it's not a very common
variation that you played but this has
been played it's nothing um nothing
terribly bad for black I don't know what
they what they play do they play b5 here
maybe really 197 those kind of things
yeah this is definitely okay I what can
black and play that it looks a bit shaky
because of this lag and development and
black has made many many pawn moves but
there is no direct refutation inside I
probably would have played something
like Roxy one or a three before this
kind of thing stabilizing the sender
leading to a position like that no it's
just slightly better for white but
nothing special g5 forever hmm I have my
doubts it really weakens quite a lot and
dd5 I think is just not working I
believe the computer wants to take with
the sea por not with the upon this is
the computer line sorry now and now him
with a clear edge for wide 1.1 then it
looks this is also quite dreadful him
like him but is there something bad with
my continuation I don't know it's also
good also plus 0.9 so it's I'm not
spoiling much but here the comp wants to
play book 81 not CD 50 interesting the
computer actually gives night XD 5s ok
for black now that I cannot believe I
absolutely cannot believe that zero
point natick Campos on a slight edge for
black and this this this is simply not
possible sorry with this kind of holes
and so on you cannot be badass like I
really don't don't think so who is the
bishop on g7 so strong
I was actually thinking about yike well
maybe I cannot play that I was thinking
I could maybe just play play this but
this might be added so funny evaluation
a computer actually evaluate this a
slightly better for black with this bad
King there on g8 poo that's a very
strange maybe it's equal i don't know i
am better for black I cannot believe and
this is a mistake then yeah so he has to
go yeah then this is really i mean i
understand this is this is definitely
better not better for black in
comparison to to the other way of
capturing so this was better I'm sorry
this was matter or maybe after this this
yeah okay I can I can do this but now I
have to play with 81 this of course
makes lots of sense you are putting the
rook opposite the Queen and this is
again a pretty clear advantage for white
yeah okay I did not I did not see the
complications correctly him but this was
this was just blundering into blundering
it away i was thinking this would happen
but if you look at this check it's not
very very a very nice f4 maybe
this is the comp line I don't know if I
would have played that but there are
many lines that are very advantageous so
um yeah nothing probably that would have
posed a big problem also here instead of
I mean here instead of oops said of
taking there are also other moves like
rock you one for example but ok bishop
age six is certainly good ok thanks for
watching